non mi ballare non mi votare no no sei
che devi tenerti non è neanche il
titanic era così triste neanche il
titano ferrose resistita di più roll
[Musica]
tutti ragazzi prendono dove sono io sono
fa vigente oggi siamo il nuovo video
incredibilmente cosa nuova
oggi farà una cosa molto particolare
perché è un videogame che mi state
consegnando lo hanno fatto tutti
praticamente proprio ancora no perché è
un videogame che si fa in due si chiama
gang beast bisogna giocare in due è la
cosa che mi fa più ridere è il giocatore
di oggi che mi accompagnerà in questa
incredibile avventura facciamo entrare
il grandissimo sfidante di turno
manca una roba giusto per essere in tema
io sono quello blu ragazzi comunque
dovevi fatta tre no tanti spingo io dai
ma come partner possibile ciao
siamo vivi entrambi non è possibile ma
vieni di qua venire a destra viene bravo
nostro negozio vivo ci credo non so come
ho fatto a rimanere vivo impossibile ma
io non ho capito amichevola vedi che
posso darti i pugni
la pratica e sto parlando sembra che sto
parlando la macarena rocky balboa vedi
guarda che tocchi affatto visto oddio
che mai ha vinto da va bene anche stare
ma da valeva tutta la partita di prima
dai non ci credo ma se mancava un cazzo
e roero giu anch'io già bravo bravo
bravo bravo bravo bello complimento
bellissimo
adesso l'ho capita che aveva capito come
bellissimo non so cosa siano mai fatte
micah p camion non ci posso credere dai
come ho fatto rimane così è non lo so se
gli scatti ha messo su dai fatti altri
sospetti grazie grazie
sentiva che cadi prima tu che io
scomparendo dalla vita stessa
lo sai che si girava visuale intanto si
stanno schiacciando i tuoi camion si
stanno schiacciando sei molto allora è
una preda aspetta aspetta aspetta chi sa
che slay prova senza e senza senza
proprio toccarmi c'è però solo a
schivare il cartellone se non ci
prendiamo mi toccare come mia basket
sono un [ __ ]
ma sono ancora vivo è sono corre e salta
salta di saltare salta bravo a te ed
esalta solo sul cambio sono vivo e sono
ancora appeso attenta a 193 lo so
l'ombra si erano
vabbè che sei più crudele di questa non
lo so ora che sa fare con le mani con le
braccia all'aria altolà il pollo e tipo
come far west
fuori dalla finestra rai ce l'abbiamo
con la finestra già sorpreso cioè che
salto affezione papi j sull'opa pg solo
ti tengo io ti tengo io ti tengo io
tranquillo ciao
e stato bellissimo conoscerti sulla
fiducia so che muore a sei vivo tieni
prendi a milano ci credo ti sei appeso
veramente no aspetta aspetta a togliersi
credo non ci vole non ci voglio credere
come caffè kosè cliccato per buttarmi
non è possibile questa in teoria si
chiama a ruota non so se è proprio la
ruota panoramica come cazzo faccia è
impossibile che ci raggiungiamo ma ora è
possibile ma è bello sono bravo a sono
vivo ancora a ecotec e moriamo a
debuttare proprio in acqua miss amiche o
buttare in acqua proprio oddio c'è il
pavimento che sismica quindi quindi è
una roba di sopra che non stai facendo
staccati dalla mia cazzo di schiena
ecco questo è quello che ti meriti che
non incontra bonci prima viene da milano
prende i premi prendimi ed ai ai lato
aggrappati a me aggrappati a me
ok
e fantastica sai che queste cose
bellissime attaccati ha attaccati a
cazzo
no no no no no no no sono caduto che
cos'era
oh mio dio non mi volare la mia votare
no no stai che devi tenerti non è
neanche il titanic era così triste
neanche alti tali ferrose resistita di
più rosa
[Musica]
una lacrima strappa storia ecco la donna
che volo successi ci posso credere
siccome arriva la metropolitana io ti
direi di biglietto lo aspetti lì c'è lo
prendi biglietto qua sotto
aspetta ecco e poi io ti aspetto sua
nota se non si riesce a salire fermo
fatto una cagata dobbiamo tentare di
salire come cazzo si sale dai dai cazzo
ha investito io sono vivo a me perché
sono in gran parte mista salvato non
puoi passare a c'è un cazzo da fare
sto facendo il mio non sto facendo un
cazzo lui e così adesso stai facendo
ma cos'è senso di questa roba lei ben sa
cosa fa a il vento che ci a cazzo e che
ne so sei morto quindi il vento ci
attira all'interno figo hai visto come
si sono un [ __ ] genio quindi se
iomega forchia cazzo cos'è addio via fa
bene impossibile da dio
il ponte è va ben hassen deficienti
entrata ho vinto io però non so come
momento io mi ha dato player 2 vince
offerteci c'è ancora io ora che non sono
mica morto aveva male che c'è che era un
osso duro dei ros non è che sei rose per
solo perché sei rose ci posso credere
ho vinto io una roba vabbè dai
[ __ ] bassa così è stato figo anche
ragazzi spero che video vi sia piaciuto
è stata una prova tanto per perché è un
gioco per da fare in due kit i ragazzi o
con quello che episodio ringrazio pochi
j per essersi prestato a questa
battaglia eterna incredibile online che
per papi j e anche per il titanic
spero che vede vi sia piaciuto a cosenza
vita piaciuta mento è un mi piace anche
a facili facebook che condivida tiziana
sensi di scadere ci mettiamo proseguito
e ragazzi complimenti per la reazione
dare mai
lasciamo perdere